all right james
james oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally columbus ohio
columbus and uh tell me about your
childhood you had both mom and dad
yeah mom and dad how would you describe
your childhood
um most of my parents drank
we had pretty good sessions so
they always were looking out for me and
buying me
gifts and stuff good childhood yeah
despite having yeah
and uh how i mean
did their drinking ever get in the way
of
your your childhood i mean have any
effects
no they just kind of neglected me
sometimes too
because of when they started drinking so
yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
uh
a rebel yeah yeah i used to
do drugs in high school and
[Music]
marijuana and i i got kicked out of high
school because of
uh white crosses
is speed somebody gave them to me
and then they told me how far did you go
in school
uh 11th grade
and you left you left home at what age
about 28 28
and the drug use kind of escalated i
guess yeah
when did you discover lsd
uh i discovered lsd when i was about
16 years old a couple of my friends
had a party and i took six hits of acid
and it was grateful dead acid because
they just went to the concert to get it
and um on my way up
on my trip uh we were watching
clockwork orange matchboard killers
and um
[Music]
beyond the mines eye
and um i looked in the mirror and one of
my peoples were bigger than the other
one
so i thought i said to myself i warped
my mind
and that that began your
your use your lsd yeah
relationship how often would you use lsd
every few months i guess
and that's continued for how many years
uh
probably 16 years yeah how old you are
i'm 46 46 off and on
yeah is it easy to get lsd today
it's not that easy around here i haven't
seen anybody with it
you're done skid row yeah where do you
stay in a tent or
winegard you're staying at the weingartz
center yeah lsd i don't see a whole lot
of people that are using lsd down here
yeah but the at the peak of your lsd use
how often would you use
uh
probably once every once a week
yeah and that would uh
how would it affect you i mean like you
you have a job and you you know you use
it when you're working
sometimes yeah yeah
i i'd see trails
and but it didn't get interfering my job
i mean i
i could still function
did you have kids no no kids you ever
had a relationship or marriage
i was married one time for seven
yeah we years them worse yeah
lsd has been something you've you've
stuck with ever since you're a kid
yeah have you tried the other drugs
i've done heroin
crank crystal meth
um marijuana
alcohol
tell us the pills
what is it about lsd that
[Music]
keeps you keeps you coming back
just
to trip out
that gets you
escape from whatever your thoughts are
or you just like
you just like being like the high that
you get
yeah it's an escape from
problems i guess you could say yeah
what are the biggest problems that
you're trying to escape from you think
i think it's
probably
just the stress of life every day
you know yeah this is there's a lot of
stress in our lives today
yeah did you have friends at this point
in your life
yeah i had a few friends
growing up but
what about today they live in tennessee
now
so i haven't talked to them in a while
yeah
how do you spend your time now are you
working or um
just
trying to get ssi
and um
for my schizophrenia oh when did you
discover you had
schizophrenia i had um
voices come in my mind
and um
i don't know if it's spirits or ghosts
or
whatever it is that causes the voices
get in my mind but
i think i talk to dead people sometimes
how often do you hear these voices uh
since i've been on medication not not
very often
are you taking the medications for
schizophrenia now yeah you are that's
good
are you tempted to stop at some point a
lot of people that are down here that
are schizophrenic will
get off the medications yeah sometimes i
do
and then what happens then well i think
i hear the
ghost of greta garbo
when you're not taking your medication
yeah yeah
and then how does lsd play into this
well
it it helps me cope with my voices
sometimes you think lsd
helps with the schizophrenia yeah is
that right
that's interesting
so what do you what do you use today
because since lsd is hard to find
uh i've been doing a lot of myths
recently
i eat it i don't smoke it i don't see it
i've been eating it and um
it gets you high that way too
and what is what does crystal meth do
for you it just gives me
amps and
makes it kind of makes you feel a
wonderful feeling
i don't know it's hard to explain but
yeah makes you harder
sometimes yeah i hear that a lot
yeah that's like the number one reason i
think guys use it
um where do you see your life going from
here i mean like
you know you're you're living in the
weingartz center which is nice you've
got a roof over your head but you're not
you're not really working you're not
doing anything um
i wanted to i came to california to
become a
movie star in hollywood
somehow yeah are you pursuing it are you
just kind of like hoping
i'm hoping but i'm wanting to pursue it
to um
[Music]
look for a producer director or
something
all right well maybe you'll find one
through this video
you never know all right james what
would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
[Music]
um
that's hard probably
just
that there's
live life for the fullest every day
seize the day
because you never know it could be your
last day on
the planet so
all right well james thank you so much
for talking with me and
i wish you the best of luck out there
thank you thank you very much
you